columnist rich lowry writing in the new
york post
quote if hunter gets indicted it's at
least going to be a significant
distraction for
president biden and raise questions
about
how much he knew about his son's sketchy
dealings
this is the kind of story voters should
be aware of when choosing a president
and they would have been if there hadn't
in effect been an american conspiracy to
misinform people led by former u.s
intelligence officials
who shamefully abused the public trust
all of that in a quote
from rick joining me now louisiana
republican senator bill cassidy senator
good to see you today
first of all tell me what is it tell me
what is at stake when you hear someone
like rich lowry writing about what the
public
didn't know going up to the presidential
election in november
well when you look back at big tech's
kind of kind of suppression of
information that could flow out there
through there many people getting their
information from big tech
now richter talks about kind of the
governmental agencies but there was
stuff out there
but when twitter takes it down and
facebook blocks access to it
that's probably to my mind the more
important thing
that's putting your thumb on the scale
of public information
in a way which definitely benefits one
side and they clearly never did that for
president trump
you know i i'm so curious as a member of
the senate you would know this i mean
everything's on the line with
retaining republican majority at this
point but how does it work to
uh to ensure that any investigation
would go forth if it's deemed necessary
and
important such as like the hunter biden
i mean who
who in the senate really would say yeah
let's get that done
yeah it depends upon who has control of
the senate it depends upon who has
control of the senate
and so georgia kind of determines that
if you care about hunter biden
no one should be guilty unless proven
guilty but no one should be above the
law
now if there is a republican senate they
will make sure the investigation is
thorough
and that no one is above the law not
even the child of a president
on the other hand you can imagine that
if we live if republicans lose in
georgia and it's a democratic senate
that will clearly not be the priority of
any committee in the senate
so how the senate does this somewhat
depends in fact entirely depends upon
the election
results down in georgia so getting to
the truth is once again
political from what you're saying well
there's certainly hopefully the
department of justice would do their job
but there's certainly political
overtones by which people decide what to
investigate and what not to
well look i want to get to something
that you have been part of
bipartisanship wise that's so critical
to america right now fox news is told
that speaker pelosi has invited top
congressional lawmakers
to negotiate the final version of the
kovit 19 relief bill
later today congress is facing a growing
push to get
something passed get something done gop
congressman steve scalise
ripped democrats demanding negotiations
continue at the end of the day we need
to get this done
they need to stop demanding ridiculous
things like bailing out failed states
and then they were trying to give checks
to people here illegally
in the country i hope we get this done
this week should have been done back in
september
senator cassidy i mentioned you're part
of that bipartisan group of lawmakers
that
presented a two-part relief package
yesterday
what can you tell us about that and do
you expect congressional leaders to
consider it entirely agree upon i think
it will be the basis of how
congressional leaders go forward
i don't know this for sure but i am told
that committees are taking this the
committees of jurisdiction
agriculture for example taking the
agricultural section
that's the basis of what they're going
to advance to that final
uh that final negotiation the second
part of the package
the second part of the package which is
the liability relief and state and local
aid
they go as a package republicans
demanding that we have liability relief
for that small business
who a year ago shifting regulations now
may be getting sued
because those shifting regulations
didn't give guidance we want liability
relief
democrats want state and local aid which
by the way with safeguards i'm okay with
state and local
aid but republicans nonetheless say if
you're getting state and local aid we
want liability
so far we've not been able to find
agreement upon liability
so that that portion of the package is
not moving
can move but there would have to be some
agreement by democrats upon our proposal
for state for for liability protection
and just so people are clear so the one
package
that includes you know the stimulus
actual stuff that people are familiar
with like those checks
is about 700 or so billion dollars that
160 or so billion is part two with that
liability
you know now you're not going to correct
you we look at
can i correct you please do the the 748
is only for emergency relief
it does not have it's not a stimulus
bill so it doesn't have the checks that
you referenced
it does have money to small businesses
nfip
suggests that one out of four are going
to go bankrupt if they don't get help
laying off their employees it does help
with vaccine distribution
more testing dollars helping schools
stay open helping folks with
unemployment relief
helping landlords and renters get
through this next couple months
uh so there's a lot of relief there but
it's not a stimulus bill
okay thank you very much for making that
clear um
and you know for real people out out in
the world who are struggling and looking
at what you're doing on capitol hill
what would you say to them today i mean
this has been a long process
yeah we've been working on this parts of
it for four months other parts for at
least a month
but this we care we're just trying to
meet those needs
and when folks went home for
thanksgiving and just saw those lines
in front of a food bank that had never
been there before and spoke to the small
business owner
who may have to shut our doors forever
even though the vaccine is being rolled
out
that just sharpened our minds even more
so this package gives that immediate
relief
to get us over the hump until that
vaccine is widely disseminated
i think it gets us there if not we'll
come back and help once more
yeah okay that's that is so important
which you have just spelled out for
what's really being talked about today
and i think i hear some optimism in your
voice just real quickly
yeah i mean folks know it has to be done
when you hear one out of four small
businesses going bankrupt
when a bunch have already gone bankrupt
and what that means for unemployment
spiking unemployment
with hospital beds filling up with his
third wave and it's
almost through i think that will just
bring people to the realization that
this has got to be done by the way we're
the only deal in town
we're the only place where democrats
republicans house and senate have come
together
so that's why i think our package will
be the way we go forward
senator cassidy i love the way you put
that you are the only deal in town
good to see you happy holidays thank you
happy holidays thank you